so we brought you here to play your
video game but it is video game history
month and we ask that you pay a game
from your past the classic as I yeah you
gave me a list and when I saw this on
the list I had to had to go yeah a thief
the dark project from 1998 this is the
Gold's this is the version that has some
extra bits and bobs on it whichever you
prefer and you come up to like here yes
I'll try that this will be good there's
a carpal tunnel yeah yeah we can think
in the just a little bit at so you
haven't played this game on guessing it
away i have not played it in some time I
don't remember what the disk of training
yeah you got it man all right try hard
skip training this game had really i
really loved so that my little trivia
around this game or one of the reasons
it's personal to me is it's the first
nine plus score that i gave a piece of
Wham well in my in my days of reviewing
games on games bought this game just
blew me away when i played it i didn't
know what to expect going into it but I
was really blown away by how how amazing
the the setting and the story of this
game was in addition to all of it just
the really great and rich game systems
here it was like nothing I'd really
played before what I'd looking that's
made up until that point they had made
so they made I its system David systems
yeah i was i was hitting on that it has
origin released it system shock was
before they did I think they did flight
unlimited to they did like a flight
simulator also but but thief was
something so wyd controls you think wise
they work i had i did it before we came
on so i got my sword i got my blackjack
if you're a thief player you know that
you should not oh man if only I knew how
to put away my blackjack it's all good
so there's a great yeah the protagonist
of this game is a great character named
Garrett and early on you find like
patrolling guards here and he's like
how's it going and you just to have that
your first amazing moment of like man
I'm a thief like no one knows hey I'm
all about that Newton is not alarmed but
yeah
lurking in the shadow you can just go
all right totally with that estate in a
nutshell say clock dudes out this game
wasn't much of a let's see how do you
right-click I think yeah yeah now so now
I am carrying homeboy around he is out
cold and I could just you know leave him
out of sight somewhere um there's that
little gem at the bottom of the screen I
don't know why stealth games did not
steal this because it is so good it
worked so well that little red night
light brighter yeah it's just telling
you how concealed you are or not and it
worked really well so yeah basically
when you're just walking around people
treat you like a civilian but as soon as
you break into one of the places that
you're trying to pilfer then you know
guards are on patrol and the game was
tuned in a really interesting way where
you know you're you're you're a thief
not a fighter so and head on fights you
tended to yeah if you got more than one
person you're gonna owe so I think this
guy I'm not gonna think he's gonna be
alright with me yeah cuz she I'm just
minding my own business not gonna call
you at hours yeah he didn't do anything
to be put for the for the viewers at
home oh yes this came out in 98 I have
to look up the exact date it was the end
of november i think it was actually two
weeks after half-life yeah i mean 90
I've 1998 it was a really insane year
for games half-life came out nice olives
metal gear solid start starcraft came
out ocarina came out like everything
came out like baldur's gate and stuff so
basically like the like a classic game
in every modern genre i think all came
out of that year so stiff thief was I
think overshadowed oh god that's
terrible to some extent by stuff like
half-life but its legacy for sure lives
on I feel like there's a whole
generation of game designers for whom
this game is is very sacred and out of
this studio came like old generation of
designers who then went on to you know
ken Levine on to rational and then folks
who may dishonored like yeah I'm out of
the studios
everywhere to go to go into that room
where that dude is like a well it's a
knock national Oh where's wrong I see
yeah he is probably just having a good
time all mine we could leave him but
again it's kind of oh he's got a key so
we can just steal the key but kneecap
there we go ice but so he'll feel that
one in the morn you are like a real lean
guy yeah whenever you pull that arm up
its I'm like yeah this game was um you
know man lurking hours think you equip
the key on ya there there's some
interface stuff you know that that's one
of the hardest things about I was looked
i always remember loving the key icon
heels about 15 years old is a mess
wheeler shoot it with arrows she's a
little war arrow everyone you can go to
the menu i'll ask i like i got some
questions here the pressing question oh
and what's your plan for the near future
once transistor is released ah I nothing
bathing the ayah is sleeping on top of a
pile of money surrounded by hundreds of
beautiful women obviously what its
massive success that's that we shall see
we in all seriousness we dont plan that
far is one of the nice things about
being small is uh yeah let's check this
out here we don't have to plan too far
ahead and for us it's like any any any
plans that we
attempt to have right now I think would
feel sort of false because use item mal
stupid you look drop item hi Jesse game
empty yeah okay I love what I went into
the good to control bindings there were
defaults for quake controlled that's
just yeah all right wine you oh you got
it at Curtis oh yeah so that is that was
like the toughest part of the game so it
looks like a loading screen to me yep
whoo how oh no loading screen how about
that but you are inside of some sort of
green soda yes yes so the green sugar
pop is an important part of the story so
pay close attention what did you think
of the sequels and I'm so deadly shadows
is kind of like a different I I liked um
I so I reviewed deadly shadows for a
game spot as a matter of fact I quite
enjoy deadly shadows more than most
people seemingly deadly shadows had a
really remarkable highly memorable level
called what was it a shell bridge cradle
that that was designed by Jordan Thomas
who became the creative director of
Bioshock 2 and like that so so that that
I remember rather vividly in thief 3
thief too was cool but it was it had
that sense of like to some extent it was
more the same for me so so it just it
didn't have as much of like the magic of
this game of like everything is new this
whole world is new and that that was
just a really amazing feeling so yeah
just like infiltrating these
environments and like finding the
characters and them the sense of you
felt really deviant like breaking into
these places and then yeah you so here
the water the water arrows this little
glass of classic part of thief and you
have these torches and you shoot a water
arrow and you put them out and guards
you know they're AI and stuff reacts to
it so there's there's a dude so this is
like a good early example where if he
just sees me he'll go to town on me but
I can
make that more difficult for him lated
we've got about a minute or two left of
this so feel free to just murder him yes
want you're speaking my language now I
want I want at last i played this about
a year ago on random encounter and was
surprised by how tense it still was yeah
because I always remembered when you got
caught in this it was it felt like game
over not really done yeah right to the
spine one degree so yeah the game I mean
I'm getting into this game just playing
it again now it's it so it's really a
fantastic game you can play it in all
kinds of crazy ways you could play it in
a really expressive way you know not
killing anyone or killing everyone as
the case may be and all sorts of stuff
so yeah thief genre classic for sure
absolutely thank you very much for a fur
four pints of people
you